cuando yo estaba diseñando estaba
imaginando me cómo iba a ser esta charla
cómo voy a hacer este momento bueno
finalmente llegó lo voy a saber lo vamos
a saber todo llega decían las abuelas
algo que yo deseaba que pase y que deseo
que pase es poder transformar esta
charla no en algo que yo les cuente sino
en algo vivencial algo que nos pase
juntos
esto tiene que ver seguramente con que
yo me dedico al teatro para quienes
hacemos teatro es una obsesión que la
palabra sea acción que la palabra llegue
que la palabra toque ojalá que la
palabra nos transforme
los quiero invitar entonces a empezar
con un ejercicio muy sencillo no vamos a
tener que actuar no va a ocurrir una
gran obra de teatro acá ni van a tener
que venir a subirse estamos bien
simplemente les pido que se aseguren de
estar cómodamente sentados vieron que
las butacas están buenas son cómodas
pero uno por ahí se sentó y quedó como
se sentó si tienen las piernas cruzadas
les sugiero descruzar las si una mochila
para agua portafolio coso cosa los está
atrapando es el momento para la
liberación
nos despertamos cuidado con el de al
lado
puede dejar esto no pasa de a muchos
bajamos cuidando al de al lado
y ahora cada uno de ustedes va a tener
que elegir una imagen personal ahora les
voy a contar de qué se trata
pero lo primero que va a pasar es que
cada uno va a elegir y que cuando va
eligiendo cuando ya la tiene
va levantando la mano así desde acá
todos sabemos y yo sé que vamos a
empezar o vamos a ir al siguiente paso
todos juntos
las imágenes
un lugar feliz de la infancia
vayan trayendo puede ser la vereda en la
que jugaban puede ser la cocina de la
abuela los domingos puede ser la colonia
de vacaciones puede ser la habitación de
ese mejor amigo o amiga puede ser la
cama de los papás a la mañana los fines
de semana tienen manteniendo levanten
así yo sé que y no siga inventando
buenísimo ahí vamos bajamos
y ahora les propongo en tornar un poco
los ojos o bajar la mirada
para que la imagen cobre aún más
dimensión
estoy en un lugar feliz de mi infancia
estoy ahí lo traigo
qué temperatura tiene el aire
puedo sentir el contacto del aire con mi
piel
hay aromas
hay un olor en particular
hay ruidos hay voces
ali encanta
alguien me llama alguien dice mi nombre
hay música
y
[Música]
cuidadosamente volvemos al momento
presente de esta charla abrimos los ojos
bienvenidos
esto que estamos escuchando es un poco
la música que yo asocie cuando armaba
este ejercicio para traérselos y
entonces lo hacía para mí gracias
yo creo que las primeras impresiones son
las que cuentan
creo que lo que conocemos a través de
los sentidos siendo chicos nos va
formando aunque no lo pensemos va
formando parte de nuestra manera de ser
de nuestra manera de percibir de que
elegimos de como somos ahora bien qué
pasa cuando siendo chicos tenemos un
encontronazo con una obra de arte esa
demasía para los sentidos esa sensación
de que ahí hay algo más tal vez no
tenemos ni idea de qué más hay o no lo
podemos poner en palabras pero estas
fuertes impresiones y este conmovernos
este saber que si tiramos de esa punta
puede haber toda una trama que se
desplieguen yo me acuerdo de estar
mirando láminas de arte por ahí un poco
sin ver siendo chica y de golpe
el bosco
yo creo que todavía sigo en ese shock no
salí para alguno habrá sido bernie y
ahora ha sido un mural habrá sido una
reproducción puede ser la música que
escuchamos por primera vez en vivo ese
hermano que trae música que es más
grande y trae música y de golpe nos
sorprendemos esas lecturas a veces del
mundo adulto
que nos demuestran que ahí hay algo más
algo disponible que la experiencia cobra
otro espesor
yo creo
que el tipo de huellas sensibles que
deliberadamente nosotros podamos
proponer en la educación de los chicos
puede hacer una diferencia para ellos en
el futuro
no lo veo como un adorno creo que es una
oportunidad para percibir para generar
imágenes imaginaciones para ampliar las
posibilidades y creo que como padres
como tíos como amigos de padres como
artistas como educadores tenemos una
oportunidad y nosotros me gustaría
también meterme con el tema de la
ficción vieron que les dije lo de la
lectura esa
qué pasa cuando la ficción encarna en el
3d más antiguo y más poderoso que hay el
teatro bueno
me dedico a escribir y creo que las
historias que contamos y nos contamos
van cambiando nuestras percepciones
cuando me revisaba armando la charla me
di cuenta que yo hace mucho mucho que
empecé a escribir
de alguna manera yo sobreviví a mi
propia infancia
crecí en una familia que no era muy apta
para cuidar de una nena
con un padre violento alcohólico con una
mamá que hizo con eso lo más que pudo
tal vez no fue todo lo que hubiera
querido y la realidad era pesada así que
yo me refugiaba un poco en esto en la
música en la danza en los libros porque
ahí era donde yo podía encontrar
historias maravillosas para vivir
historias para mí
y como estaba buenísimo
empecé a ficcionario usaba toda la
imaginación de la que disponía
para adornar la realidad agrandar
inventar ante una ausencia difícil
inventaba un viaje increíble ante un
momento de mayor soledad me inventaba un
escenario mucho más mejor
fue pasando el tiempo yo salía adelante
me pude alejar de situaciones que me
hacían mal
pero
no me aleje del arte lo abrace ahora
como como oficio
en 2009
gustavo ferrari por ahí lo encuentran
también por acá y silvina cats que
también por ahí lo encuentran
me convocaron para escribir y dirigir
obras de teatro educativo para un
proyecto que nacía
eureka arte más educación
gustavo lo pueden ver en la foto que
elegí es un optimista inclaudicable
contra todo riesgo entonces él estaba
desbordado de felicidad cuando nos
contaba la idea que tenía porque él
sabía que el futuro del proyecto era
enorme y lo único que necesitaba era que
quienes nos íbamos a sumar pudiéramos
ver lo que él estaba viendo
yo no sé si vi lo que estaba viendo no
sé me acuerdo mucho de la reunión y me
acuerdo de sentir y ojalá si no les pasó
todavía les pase me están ofreciendo el
trabajo de mi vida
dónde hay que firmar dónde es la salida
en la que me voy a meter
estos dos sabrán en la que se están
metiendo y me van a meter
porque nos estábamos metiendo en algo
complicado el desafío era poder contar
historias apasionantes aventuras e
historias con misterio con humor con
acción historias donde los chicos
quedaran enganchadísimo estamos hablando
de los nativos digitales enganchadísimo
que lo vivieron a tope y entré a amar
esas mismas historias con contenidos
teóricos
vieron esos que en el aula
como no hacen sentido con la realidad de
los chicos quedan ahí como un dato
después llega la prueba después ya fue
todo esos
bueno como contaba andy la trama
creativa es compleja pasamos por muchos
periodos armamos por supuesto un gran
equipo delante y detrás de escena y
ustedes todos saben que si yo hoy estoy
parada acá es porque esto tiene un final
feliz
voy a spoiler les es el final porque yo
creo que siempre la importancia está en
la trama y en cómo se la recorra mucho
más que en los desenlaces
en estos nueve años estrenamos siete
espectáculos para chicos medianos y
adultos vieron nuestras obras casi un
millón de personas
hicimos estas funciones en escuelas
annecy teatros teatros clubes pasillos
escenarios móviles
y estrenamos también el corazón de
nuestro proyecto que es lo que están
viendo una saga de superhéroes muy anti
héroes que cumplen los casos más
difíciles
aprendimos muchas cosas
me gustaría compartirlas con ustedes
como no queríamos infantilizar a los
chicos
desistimos de peluche voz aguda
diminutivos y nos enfocamos en un
universo muy recital era muy recital
hero con unos superhéroes excluidos
eloísa emilia y eliseo que invitan a los
chicos a ser parte de su pandilla y los
chicos devienen superhéroes en cada una
de las aventuras
les dimos un arma como de alfombra roja
y como de estrella de rock a los
superhéroes y el mayor superpoder que
siempre tienen es la fuerza de su
corazón y el creer que las cosas pueden
cambiar
como vamos a desembarcar todos los días
en las escuelas creíamos que los chicos
tenían que tener en sus manos que pasaba
el desenlace entonces siempre en
nuestros casos hay un momento en que
todo está por salir mal todos quedamos
desahuciados y los personajes dejan ese
espacio esa sensación de misión
imposible ahí son los espectadores los
que les ofrecen su ayuda cuando dejamos
en las manos de los chicos la resolución
de los casos les estamos diciendo dos
cosas por un lado que ellos tienen el
poder que tienen el poder de con sus
acciones intervenir y por otro lado que
lo que se aprende no es algo que nos dan
es algo que construimos a medida que lo
necesitamos a medida que se vuelve vital
los adultos sabemos que de las
experiencias se aprenden a veces con
bastante costó pero se aprende poder
propiciarles a los chicos una
experiencia a través de todos los
sentidos nos permite hacerlos vivir
situaciones como no sé un desastre
ambiental o un accidente de tránsito
pero amparados por la ficción
aprendimos que no hay ninguna
competencia para batallar con la
tecnología pusimos mapping escenografías
interactivas audiovisuales nos ayudan a
ampliar el espacio y el tiempo y los
chicos se enganchan con lo que pasa en
vivo con poder estar conectados con
ellos mismos con quien tienen al lado y
con los personajes porque estos
personajes siempre los miran
horizontalmente nunca los miran de
arriba hacia abajo
su aprendiz
que soy la primera persona de esta
historia a la que la ficción le cambió
la vida
todo lo que consideramos real es
construido
nuestra subjetividad nuestra percepción
va modificando lo que historias nos
contemos puede cambiar nos pueden
hacernos resilientes la fantasía
entendida en serio puede ser nuestro
motor porque es fantasear tiene que ver
con soñar con imaginar escenarios
mejores y dar pasos para que sean
posibles
estamos educando a los chicos ahora para
un futuro no tenemos la más remota idea
de cómo hacer alguien sabe
aparece mucho la tecnología como un cuco
terrible o como nuestra salvación de
todas maneras nosotros vamos a seguir
ahí tomando decisiones de qué hacer con
la tecnología así que abrir la puerta a
la experiencia sensible abrir la puerta
a la capacidad de percibir de imaginar
de soñar de empatizar es una muy buena
oportunidad para abrir la puerta para ir
a jugar en serio
los dejo con el público de eureka los
chicos que saben que lo que sueñan hoy
puede mover la realidad mañana gracias
[Aplausos]